thank you
[Applause]
thank you yeah you guys are unbelievable
it is awesome to be back here such a
thrill thank you all for joining us I
have to start by saying that we have an
unbelievable time so much fun with you
every year at QuakeCon but there is just
nothing like these years where we get
the opportunity to show you what our
team is working on it is the best thing
ever and we wouldn't want to debut doom
eternal anywhere but right here to you
at QuakeCon actually how many of you are
here in 2014 when we shared our first
look at the last doom yeah that's
awesome
well special thanks to you for joining
us again and for your continued support
also thanks to everyone watching on the
streams it's great to have you here with
us this year so let's get to it you
ready to rip and tear that's awesome
because literally that's where it all
starts for us
killing badass demons with big guns in
unbelievable places absolutely and as
the doom Slayer you want to feel
Unleashed right like nothing is holding
you back to have a pure unfiltered
action FPS experience and to do that we
started with a very simple goal make him
the strongest and most powerful hero
we've ever created so as you could see
in these concept illustrations he's had
a bit of an update a modification to his
armor and some new tools and abilities
that make him even more lethal of course
nothing makes the Slayer more lethal
than his guns like the ballista a gun
that can spear demons with an explosive
bolt
or the Slayers own super shotgun oh yeah
I love this it's like his Excalibur and
you'll notice there's a little thing on
the end there we call it the meat hook
and you're gonna love what you could do
with that thing it's it's totally my new
favorite but this is what's great
everybody has a different favorite gun
because each is a unique and powerful
tool for killing the biggest and baddest
demons you've ever seen that's right
because you know a hero is only as
strong as the enemies he defeats so if
you want to feel like a badass
you got to wreck some amazing bad guys
along the way and do maternal has some
incredible enemies bit of an FY as many
as last time these guys are insane yeah
we've updated some favorites reimagine
some classics from doom to like the
arachnid Tron pain elemental
and we got some new bad guys for you to
destroy - check out this arch enemy of
the Slayer and how about this guy the
Marauder
you know anybody noticed he kind of
looks like the Slayer that's pretty cool
is the story behind that you know the
coolest enemies deserve the coolest
deaths so we're spending more time and
energy than ever before making sure it
feels absolutely amazing every time you
shoot punch kick slash or otherwise rip
and tear one of the demons actually
weave act we've created like a whole
system for this now and internally we
call it destructible demons you're gonna
get to see a lot of that yeah all right
they know what's coming they always know
what's coming
yeah you ready all right
well you know what I know the answer to
the question but you ready to see him in
action let's rock
[Music]
please remain calm you may notice a
slight sweet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or delete
[Applause]
we're actually that's awesome thank you
we're actually just just taking a very
very brief break we have we have a lot
more to a lot more gameplay from hell on
earth to show you actually but for this
next stuff we wanted to actually pick up
the pace just a little bit yeah how
about we go full bore and really see
what this layer can do maybe a little
fov change little mouse and keyboard you
guys like the mouse creepy bro all right
all right buckle up
earth is the melting pot of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
all right thank you so glad you're
having fun so you probably noticed there
at the end that we're now giving players
the ability to take control of a demon
and invade another player's campaign
right you can actually even team up as
demons to form a slayer hunting party
yep it's all just a really fun new way
to add drama and unpredictability to
your campaign and this is just one of
the ways that will allow you to enjoy
doom eternal with your friends of course
it's up to you if you want to invade be
invaded or you just want to rip and tear
by yourself in your own campaign totally
up to you we're really excited about
invasion and you can look forward to a
lot more on this down the road
all right we've we spent a bit of time
so far just giving you a taste of Hell
on earth but that is just one of the
many many places you'll go
yeah we do a lot of environmental
storytelling in Doom eternal we get to
see how the UAC evolved journey into new
and fantastic places inhale and take you
to some places you've never been before
in a doom game wonder what that is
we love our little pin honestly we're
we're just huge
Laure nerds at it and everything we do
has a story behind it so if you like me
and you like to investigate everything
we're gonna make it worth your time it's
really true
we're not just making a doom game
anymore we're building a Doom universe
you also know we're we're pretty big
tech heads at it and this it text yeah
and as you've seen all without
sacrificing a crazy fast experience
running at 60 frames per second
absolutely all right you know what we've
actually got another one of those cool
locations we just talked about you guys
want to see a little more gameplay
alright you can never say no to quake on
so let's take a look at what happens
when the Slayer arrives on Phobos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
Oh guys are unbelievable yeah thank you
so much really glad you liked it that
was awesome
I you know I still like watching it I
know I know I was so cool should play it
it's great yes you well that's right
you know it honestly it takes an entire
team of dedicated and talented
developers to working hard together to
make what you just saw today so it's
truly an honor for us to be able to come
up here and represent the amazing group
of people that we get to work with both
at our offices in Dallas and in
Frankfurt Germany and because we are
lucky enough to be here at QuakeCon we
have many from our Dallas office here in
attendance so before we go we would like
to ask everybody from it to stand up so
you can see who they are and they can
feel some of the love
good work guys yeah amazing guys and
girls awesome
thank you we love this this was
absolutely a blast you make it awesome
for us we'll see you around
[Music]
[Applause]